so let's talk about one of the best
remedies for cardiac arrhythmias
now whether we're talking about minor
palpitations or
atrial fibrillation one of the big
problems with a severe
arrhythmia issue is that the blood can
pool in different parts of the heart and
create clotting
and then that can actually turn into a
stroke when you go to the doctor
they'll treat it with either a beta
blocker a calcium channel blocker
or digitalis what i want to do in this
video is give you an alternative
but of course check with your doctor
before
discontinuing any of this medication
that being said the unifying theory or
agreement
that most of the medical professionals
have about
an arrhythmia is that there's a problem
with calcium
calcium is leaking from the cardiac
cells
calcium is very very necessary in the
body but if there's too much in the
cells that can be very
toxic and if there's too much outside
the cell
that can be very toxic as well now
there's many different
purposes of calcium in the body but one
huge
function of calcium is it's a signaling
molecule or a messenger type
molecule that causes certain functions
to occur
in certain pathways calcium also affects
another signaling molecule
which is right here i don't want to get
into the details
camp the only thing i want you to know
about this right now is
it's another signaling molecule and it
works with
calcium when you have arrhythmias
there's going to be a problem with this
and a problem with this thus the
medication a calcium channel
blocker and another medication used for
arrhythmias called digitalis
which affects the sodium calcium
relationship
in past videos i talked about potassium
deficiencies and magnesium deficiencies
causing arrhythmias and the reason why
these two
would work is because both of these
minerals
help balance calcium and keep calcium
from becoming too toxic
inside the cell and if you have an
advanced arrhythmia
you could be pretty deficient in
magnesium and potassium and that could
take some time to
fortify your body it could take actually
even months
but in the meantime there's a really
good remedy that i'm going to recommend
d-ribose and d is actually
the natural form of ribose and ribose
is a signaling molecule for this
other signaling molecule okay it's kind
of like a precursor
or a building block for this right here
because it improves
cardiac muscle physiology it's also
recommended when you have cramps
or soreness in the muscle after you
exercise
so it tends to bypass the damaged
pathways in the heart
and it gets the myocardial cells the
heart muscles
to work better it also can reduce angina
it's also good for reducing fibromyalgia
chronic fatigue syndrome and the dosage
i'm going to recommend
would be five grams two
to three times a day you don't want to
go over five grams because sometimes it
can actually
give you a little digestive problem
maybe it's too much gas or even diarrhea
so stick with five grams
two to three times a day and you'll
notice that this will give you a lot of
relief
some people mix this with their coffee
because caffeine aggravates
arrhythmias but adding this to it will
tend to
rid the jittery feelings or the abnormal
extra palpitations you may get when you
consume
caffeine and i also want to add this you
probably already know this but
drinking alcohol causes arrhythmias
chronic stress
can cause arrhythmias of course eating
food that depletes your potassium
magnesium will cause arrhythmias
a lot of refined carbs and sugars and
refined grains
and also a diet low in potassium
magnesium and that would be a diet
that's low
in vegetables an average american
consumes only 1.5 cups of vegetables so
i don't know where they're getting their
minerals from but over time that can
lead to
problems with the heart also exposure to
emf
i've done a video on this in the past
and this is a big problem especially if
you're sitting in front of your computer
all day long what's going to happen is
the
electromagnetic fields from those
electrical devices
can interfere with your own electrical
fields and create
arrhythmias just right here so you may
want to get that checked definitely work
on these things
okay to actually get to the bottom of
the arrhythmias
and you may want to start taking this
remedy to give you some
relief in the meantime i personally
don't sell this product
i don't recommend a brand you're going
to have to do your research on
on that part thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next video
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains
no sugar totally keto there's no
suffering on keto absolutely not karen
and it's an immune system builder
absolutely
you have to check this out i think you
should hurry up watch the recipe
and make it yourself it's just so easy
to be keto
but is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy
making it as much as we are enjoying
eating it